let's go to our caller from the 7:01
area code who's calling from 7-0 room
today hello
yeah that's you okay sorry sorry
this is Nathan from North Dakota great
so my question is so I live about a
hundred miles south of the border of
Canada and North Dakota is a deep like
in my opinion deep red red state yes so
if if heaven forbid sound a little
nervous that's okay
it hasn't prepared that don't um Quinn's
another term yes what have you seen as
an act of cowardice to move to the north
to Canada there I I mean I wouldn't call
it cowardice I would call it pragmatic
it's difficult to move to Canada so I
don't know that it's that easy to do
but I wouldn't see it as an act of
cowardice no I would see it as hey I'm
taking control of my life the election
didn't go my way I believe that this is
such a danger I don't want to be
governed by this orange maniac I'm going
to go somewhere else I mean if you it's
good work if you can get it so to speak
like it's difficult to move to Canada
but if you're able to do it I would not
call that cowardice at all mm-hmm yeah
with everything going on it's just I
don't think I could take another another
four years of living in a country where
just seeing what the leader is doing now
could you move to Canada like do you
have relatives there or how would you do
it legally yes I have about my mom's
side I have an entire set of family over
there Wow well that's certainly
something to think about you know a lot
of people talk about I'm gonna move to
Canada if X or Y very few people ever
really do it so it would be it would be
an interesting thing to look at all
right thank you for the phone call I
don't know that we've ever had a caller
from noir
the coda it's interesting